wie viel kostet ein
wie viel kostet ein bier ein bier kostet
5 franken 70 ein bier kostet 5 franken
viel kostet ein orangensaft wie
viel kostet ein orangensaft ein
orangensaft kostet 4 franken 50
ein
schon saft kostet 4 franken 50
möchtest du einen kaffee möchtest du
einen kaffee ja gern ja gern
nein danke nein danke möchten sie etwas
trinken möchten sie etwas trinken ja
gern ich möchte eine tasse tee bitte ja
gern ich möchte eine tasse tee bitte
nein danke
ich habe
den durst nein danke
ich habe keinen durst ich nehme einen
kaffee ich nehme einen kaffee nimmst du
auch einen kaffee nimmst du auch einen
kaffee
kann ich ihnen helfen kann ich ihnen
helfen gern ich suche eine hose ja gern
ich suche eine hose nein danke
ich schaue nur nein danke ich schaue nur
passen die ihr die schuhe passen die ihr
die schuhe
sie passen mir ja sie passen mir nein
sie passen mir nicht
nein sie passen mir nicht
passt ihr die hose passt dir die hose
sie passt mir nein sie passt mir nicht
sie passt mir nicht
wo ist hier das wc wo ist hier das wc
können sie mir sagen wo ihr das vize ist
können
sie mir sagen wo ihr das wc ist im
winter ist es kalt im winter ist es kalt
es gibt schnee es gibt schnee die
temperaturen sind oft unter null grad
celsius
die temperaturen sind oft unter null
grad celsius im sommer ist es warm oder
heiß
ist es waren oder heiß
die sonne
scheint die sonne scheint es gibt mal
mal gewitter es gibt manchmal gewitter
im herbst ist es kühl
[Musik]
es regnet es oft es regnet oft im
frühling ist es warm im frühling ist es
warm
es ist oft sonnig es ist oft sonnig
die dusche ist im badezimmer die dusche
ist im badezimmer der herz ist in der
küche der herz ist in der küche
das bett ist im schlafzimmer das bett
ist im schlafzimmer der fernseher steht
im wohnzimmer der fernseher steht im
wohnzimmer die pflanze steht auf dem
balkon die pflanze steht auf dem balkon
gibt es einen balkon gibt es einen
balkon
ja es gibt einen balkon
nein es gibt keinen balkon
mir gefällt der kleiderschrank mir
gefällt der kleiderschrank
er ist groß er ist groß ich möchte ihn
kaufen
ich möchte ihn kaufen
mehr
fällt das bett mir gefällt das bett es
ist bequem
es ist bequem
ich möchte es kaufen
fällt die lampe mir gefällt die lampe
sie ist modern
ich möchte
kaufen ich möchte sie kaufen
mir gefallen die vorhänge mir gefallen
die vorhänge sie sind schön sie sind
schön
ich möchte sie kaufen
ich muss die welt
waschen
ich muss die wäsche waschen du musst die
kleiderbügeln du musst die kleiderbügeln
er muss das geschirr abwaschen
wir müssen die lebensmittel einkaufen
ihr müsst den müll rausbringen
sie müssen die wohnung putzen sie müssen
die wohnung putzen
können wir bezahlen
können wir bezahlen bitte
ja gern bezahlen sie zusammen oder
getrennt
getrennt getrennt bitte
wer bezahlt was ich bezahle das stück
pizza die portion pommes die tasse
kaffee und die dose cola
ich bezahle das stück pizza die portion
pommes die tasse kaffee und die dose
cola
und ich bezahle den teller pasta den
becher eis das glas orangensaft und die
flasche so da und ich bezahle den teller
pasta den becher eis das glas
orangensaft und die flasche oder er
stellt das gemüse er stellt das gemüse
er schneidet das gemüse er schneidet das
gemüse er dreht das essen an
er dreht das essen an
er kocht eine suppe er kocht eine suppe
er probiert die suppe er probiert die
suppe
ich mag gemüse ich mag gemüse ich esse
gern gemüse ich esse gern gemüse
ich mag wein
ich trinke gern wein
können sie mir helfen können sie mir
helfen
wo ist hier die kasse
wo ist hier die kasse gehen sie
geradeaus und dann nach links gehen sie
als und dann nach links
gehen sie nach rechts und dann geradeaus
gehen sie nach rechts um dann geradeaus
die zitrone ist sauer
[Musik]
die banner
anne ist süß
ist süß der pfeffer ist scharf der
pfeffer ist scharf der kaffee
ist bitter der kaffee
ist bitter guten morgen
guten morgen
guten tag
guten abend
guten abend gute nacht
gute nacht was ist ihr beruf
ist ihr beruf
mein beruf ist anwältin
haben sie kinder
ja ich habe einen sohn
ich mache yoga
ich mache yoga ich spiele gitarre
ich spiele gitarre
ich höre gerne musik
ich schwimme gern
[Musik]
siehst du oft
fern
siehst du
ja ich sehe oft fern
nein ich sehr selten fern
nein ich sehe selten fern
wohin gehst du
ich gehe in die schuhe
ich gehe in die schule
ich gehe in die stadt
ich gehe ins restaurant
ich gehe in den park
ich gehe in den supermarkt
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video